votre nom je sais comment voyez-vous
votre prénom
vous ne touchez à rien je ne donne pas
trop bien tout se joue en l'espace de
quelques instants pour réunir les
informations nécessaires et engagé si
besoin une ou plusieurs patrouilles à
merville à le garric d'accord ici au
centre d'opérations et de renseignement
de la gendarmerie 150 à 200 appels sont
gérés par jour plusieurs personnes sont
ainsi présentes sur place pour répondre
aux yvelinois qui compose le 17
et gérer des cas qui peuvent varier du
simple accident domestique aux
agissements les plus graves
on peut aussi avoir des gens qui sont en
urgence parce que ils sont sur le point
de se faire assassiner ça a été on a eu
ce cas là une femme qui s'effectue en
direct par exemple eh bien on a eu la
chance de pouvoir lui demander où est ce
qu'elle était et qu'elle a donné elle a
donné sa position
en fait on est arrivé c'était trop tard
mais
mais l'auteur était resté sur place
était son mari on peut aussi avoir des
gens qui sont tout petits des enfants ou
des personnes plus âgées où il faut
parler plus fort ce qu'ils entendent par
là qu'est tout
au total dix huit gendarmes se relaient
jour et nuit pour assurer le
fonctionnement du centre d'appels parmi
eux le chef fabien p o
alors le civet qu'est ce que tu m'as dit
que tu avais comme une peugeot 309 c'est
ça pour être opérationnel il a dû suivre
une formation et développer de nouvelles
capacités pour avoir un sens de l'écouté
il faut avoir une certaine une certaine
rigueur dans la retranscription des
événements et il faut avoir certaines
sang froid de telle sorte à ce qu'on
soit pas embarquer entre guillemets par
l'affect de la personne qui nous
appellent et qui peut-être en panique
tous les personnels ont déjà un vécu
déjà avant on a tous été en brigade donc
voilà on comprend pas des jeunes sortis
d'école il ya déjà un passif faire
passer tous les personnels ici ont un
sang froid et surtout se mettre dans
leur bulle quand il on l'appelle l'appel
justement celui ci ne dépasse pas
généralement plusieurs minutes
une série de questions simples et
basiques permettent de faire un état des
lieux et de mesurer la gravité de la
pelle ce premier contact permet aussi
d'assurer la sécurité des forces de
l'ordre engagé sur place et nous on a
une difficulté de perception de
l'événement
ça peut avoir d' assez lourdes
conséquences sur les victimes mais ça
peut être au ca peut avoir aussi
d'autres conséquences plus lourdes sur
les personnels de secours qui vont
intervenir l'an passé le centre
d'opérations et de renseignement de la
gendarmerie de versailles a reçu près de
110 mille appels ceux ci ont entraîné
l'intervention d'une patrouille dans un
cas sur trois